what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like Sony
and Marvel Studios could be up to
something right now as the latest
reports and rumors say that Disney slash
Marvel Studios because Disney owns
Marvel Studios and Sony are on the verge
of a brand new Spider-Man deal now
what's really interesting is that none
of us really know the details of what
went on and what was included or not
included and the last deal that Sony and
Disney slash Marvel Studios made however
there have been rumors and reports that
the deal was only for three movies or at
least the contract only lasted until
Spider-Man no way home and considering
that that was the finale of a Trilogy
that does make sense however we do know
that Marvel and Sony do want to do more
Spider-Man movies in fact Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios and Amy
Pascal an executive producer over at
Sony did confirm after no way home came
out right right after no way home came
out they confirmed that they are already
working on a Spider-Man 4. and now it
seems like it's apparently far enough
along the lines to start getting a deal
done for the movies and specifically for
Tom Holland after the deal for the
movies and Spider-Man as a character is
made but this deal is also going to
involve the Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
which Spider-Man should be appearing in
both of them now before people start to
get worried because the last time they
renegotiated a Spider-Man deal in the
MCU it got pretty scary we almost didn't
have Spider-Man in the MCU anymore for a
while Sony and Marvel Studios could not
work out a deal and it looked like we
were going to permanently lose
Spider-Man however since then since that
deal was made Spider-Man has done
wonders in the box office and the MCU
and all of the reports state that Marvel
Studios and Sony are working extremely
well with each other right now in fact
even in Sony's Spider-Man vs Sony
consults with Kevin feige for each
Spider-Man related project even though
that project is not going to be in the
MCU however with a new Spider-Man deal
coming into play now perhaps some of the
two universes might blend just a little
bit because of everything that we've
been hearing about Sony spider-verse is
true they are definitely going to want
Tom Holland Spider-Man in their Universe
at least once or twice in the universe
that they are building they seemingly
are building up to a spider get in film
which is basically a secret Wars a big
Multiverse Collision of a ton of
different Spider-Man variants so imagine
seeing about 20 to 40 Spider-Man
variants on the same screen all fighting
together and possibly against each other
that's what Sony could have up their
sleeve for their Sony Spider-Man
universe but first let's talk about this
deal between Sony and Marvel Studios and
what Marvel Studios has planned for
Spider-Man in the MCU now we've known
for a little bit that Sony and Marvel
Studio Disney are going to be making a
new deal but according to a new report
word from Grace Randolph yesterday she
says it seems Disney and Sony are close
to new Spider-Man deal they sign then
can work on Tom Holland's deal hashtag
Spider-Man 4 and likely both Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars now let me just
explain one line in her tweet here she
says they sign then can work on Tom
Holland's deal now when she says they
sign at first she is talking about the
actual character Spider-Man the deal
isn't specifically talking about Tom
Holland Spider-Man at first it's just
simply talking about keeping Spider-Man
in the MCU since Sony does own the rides
for Spider-Man on screen so basically
what they have to work out is what's the
cut how much is Sony gonna make how much
is Marvel gonna make and the good news
is is this has pretty much been worked
out already this is what the last big
deal was about when we almost lost
Spider-Man in the MCU Marvel won and
more because Spider-Man homecoming was
the first Spider-Man movie to hit a bill
million dollars and yes Spider-Man is
popular but this was also due to the
fact that Spider-Man was in the MCU he
interacted with the Avengers in Captain
America Civil War and Tony Stark was in
homecoming so Marvel Studios had a big
part to play in that billion dollar
movie so naturally given the success
they wanted a little bit more of a cut
like I said they worked that out already
and figured out something that works for
both of them so we're in the clear on
that what they have to work out now is
how many movies is Spider-Man going to
be in moving forward what is this next
deal going to be for are they going to
do a new Spider-Man trilogy and what
team up movies is Spider-Man going to
appear in Gray specifically mentions
Spider-Man 4 the King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars we obviously have
to have Spider-Man 4 before the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars comes out
because there is a lot left unanswered
about Spider-Man is anybody going to
remember who Peter Parker is is the
spell going to be undone is he finally
going to talk to Ned and MJ is is Ned
going to become a villain is spider-gwen
going to come to the picture as miles
morale is going to be introduced there's
so much to address in the next
Spider-Man movie so Spider-Man 4 is the
first thing that needs to happen and
according to the latest reports
Spider-Man 4 could be releasing on June
7th of 2024 which means we probably are
not going to be getting Spider-Man 5 or
6 before the King Dynasty or Secret Wars
they would come after and this also sets
something else up we'll talk about that
in just a bit but first big thank you to
wondery and the Lords of the Ring
podcast for sponsoring this video now I
know a lot of you like me have watched
The Lord of the Rings the rings of power
on Amazon it's amazing I loved it and
since you're on my Channel right now you
probably love to dive even deeper than
just watching the show and now you can
go deeper into the canals of numenor the
minds of kazadum and more with the
official the Lord of the Rings rings of
power podcast host Felicia Day who many
people probably know and several special
guests provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking Series in and what it
took to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
showrunner DJ Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of the incredible season finale Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you jaw-dropping
stories and Easter eggs you won't want
to miss watch the rings of power on
Prime video and listen to all eight
episodes of the official the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast for
free on Amazon music download the Amazon
music app right now to listen to The
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast
the reason that it's a big deal that the
King Dynasty and Secret Wars would come
before Spider-Man 5 and Spider-Man 6 is
because of the Venom symbiote the
post-credits scene for Spider-Man no way
home set up Venom in the MCU not the
same Venom from the Sony Universe not
Tom Hardy's Venom sadly but the Venom
symbiote and the latest rumor is that
Tom Holland is not going to be getting
this symbiote until after Secret Wars to
keep to a comic accurate story because
in the comics the first time that
Spider-Man ever wears the Black Venom
symbiote suit is during Secret Wars so
I'm all for this because I do like to
see comic accurate stories play out in
the MCU also not to mention in Sony's
new Spider-Man deal they could also make
a deal for Tom Hardy's Venom to show up
in secret Wars we know that there are
going to be many different variants of
many different characters in this movie
universes are going to be colliding so
why not have Tom Hardy's Venom in there
even if it's just for a quick little
Cameo now Dr Strange and seemed to know
about the whole Spider-Man debacle both
seem to know about the spell gone wrong
it's unclear whether they know Peter
Parker as Spider-Man or not but they do
know about the Spider-Man spell and
people still do know about Spider-Man so
regardless of whether or not the spell
is reversed or people find out who Peter
Parker really is AKA Spider-Man he is
going to be involved in the next
Avengers film which is the Kang Dynasty
that is being written right now so it
would make sense that the New Deal for
Spider-Man would have to get done right
now so the fact that it's close to being
done is good news because you can't have
an Avengers film at this point in time
without Spider-Man he's one of the only
characters left from the infinity Saga
that we still have in the Multiverse
Saga we need those old characters to
remain and plus the King Dynasty is
going to lead right into Secret Wars and
since we know he's going to be in secret
Wars it only makes sense for him to be
in the Kang Dynasty and then like I said
hopefully we get a Spider-Man 5 and a
Spider-Man 6 in Phase 6 and phase 7 and
Beyond and hopefully this is when Marvel
Studios will start to introduce other
Spider-Man characters into the MCU like
Miles Morales like they teased and
Spider-Man no way home talking about
there's got to be a black Spider-Man out
there somewhere so this is great news we
don't have to worry about Spider-Man
going anywhere Sony and Marvel Studios
are working out a new deal right now to
get Spider-Man back in the MCU so let me
know how excited you are about this in
the comments down below and let me know
what story lines you'd like to see in
the MCU for Spider-Man in the comments
as well don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest Spider-Man news for
live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign